[Music]
[Applause]
luno the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh
pen show it is powered by icon plus
capital the vc firm
so today is a really interesting topic
the world has gone pretty crazy
recently um a kind of division that i
haven't seen in my lifetime
so i'm going to delve into this with a
good friend of mine but before i do i
just want to let you know that this
is as usual sponsored by blockfi you can
get amazing interest rates with them and
i think around 250
when you sign up and this particular
episode is actually sponsored by compass
mining
huge thanks to them because without them
obviously we won't be able to make these
amazing shows and really just like speak
the truth so um
compass mining so they actually make
bitcoin mining accessible for everyone
you just buy your machine pick a hosting
facility and let them do the work so if
you do want to start mining bitcoin then
just head to compassmining.io
so let's start the show joining me today
is the founder and co-host of
trigonometry it is constant kissing
constant how are you doing
i'm good leah it's pronounced
constantine by the way constantine
i'm sorry i didn't get that fully right
that's all right now officially racist
uh no oh my god stop it
i i love it when people get into that
mispronouncing people's name sahar makes
you you know a bigger it makes me laugh
but
i'm good it's good to be with you i've
been uh we've been following each other
for a while on social media i really
enjoy the stuff that you put out
and maybe you can explain to me what
bitcoin is all about
uh i think i told you uh in like 2011 or
something i bought half a bitcoin for
four hundred dollars
uh and i was like whatever i held on to
it for about
three or four years and when i checked
back into my account
it was worth twice as much as what i
ported for so i was like oh my god this
is amazing i better sell this before
this crashes
and so i got eight hundred dollars for a
bitcoin uh so
you know that's my the extent of my
experience with it wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait i just need to
like press you on that sorry how much
bitcoin did you say you had
i had a bitcoin just one bitcoin
and you sold it for 800 pounds
yeah oh my god that is crazy how do you
feel about it
well you know i'm jewish right so how am
i supposed to feel about losing money
stop i hate the like i'm really bad with
jokes like that like i'm
okay so i don't get offended easily but
i i get really weird
with like jokes like that i don't know
why it just makes me feel so funny
but i hear you i hear you okay i'm with
you i'm with
yeah that's that's the whole point of
jokes to make people feel uncomfortable
i actually agree with you so before we
delve in i'm actually going to press you
on this before we delve into it
just can you tell people about your
background obviously um
you know you're the co-host of the
trigonometry podcast um
great show watched it love it tell
people about it and also where it came
from
well so the long story short is that i'm
originally from russia i was born in the
soviet union in the early 80s
my parents sent me to boarding school in
the 90s in the uk
when my dad was very briefly a sort of
mini oligarch
before he lost all his money uh and
that's why i ended up in the uk uh i
initially
i had to drop out of university because
my my family ran out of money because
actually my dad
was um he was accused falsely of
various things and russia had to escape
russia under a false name
and as a result of that lost all his
money he was a minister in boris
yeltsin's government at the time
um and as a result of that i actually
ended up
at university halfway through university
not having enough money to even be able
to
uh carry on with my studies not only
that i didn't even have enough money to
pay rent
and i ended up sleeping on the street
for about three weeks
uh in in scotland in in in the scottish
summer
uh before eventually you know starting
my own business with translation which
was what i did
for for about 10 years had a lot of
success with that
i was probably you know the number one
translator in my language pair and in my
fields
i then started teaching other people the
business skills of of that particular
industry how to negotiate with clients i
studied a lot of
psychology nlp hypnotherapy all that
sort of like
communication stuff which i found very
useful and then i got very bored of it
because
to me the thing about life is always
want to be moving forward and once you
get
to a point in an industry or in a field
where it's like you've got nothing else
to do i kind of wanted to move on and be
bad at something again
so i started comedy and that's how i
became a comedian
in about 2014 2015 i did that for a few
years and i very quickly realized that
the industry i was now in
was going in a direction that was very
unexpected to me so
to me comedy was always about uh
challenging the na the narratives that
we're being
fed by the mainstream about questioning
things about
pointing out things that don't make
sense about society and all of those
sort of things and i thought when i went
into comedy later
that that is where people like me go
like if you want to push back if you
want to challenge things
you go into comedy uh and what happened
i
i very quickly discovered actually that
that's completely not true
uh comedy is full of the most atrocious
conformism
and group think and heard mentality that
you could imagine
and partly as a pushback to that but
partly also as a pushback to many of the
things that happen in society more
broadly which i'm sure we'll talk about
uh i realized that i wanted to
understand what was happening because
as a dark-skinned immigrant to britain
who voted romaine who thought you know
all this liberal stuff was gray and blah
blah blah
what happened in 2016 for me was i've
lived in this country for nearly over 20
years now
and people started saying to me people
who were my friends people who i'd known
for many years
well the reason this country voted to
leave the uk
is that this is a racist country
and i was like well that's just not true
i i just know that through my own
experience i'm not saying no one's ever
been
rude or bigoted towards me but that
doesn't necessarily mean that the
country itself is racist or that there
are many people like that right
i grew up in russia where uh there were
plenty of stupid people who were
prejudiced and bigoted against
others so to me this i just i just knew
that wasn't true
right that explanation of the things
that started happening in 2016
was not accurate and so my friend and
co-host francis foster who we do
trigonometry with we were like well
let's start a show
where we try and understand we talk to
people who actually understand what's
going on
why this particular thing happened about
what's going on and that's really the
genesis of trigonometries
two comedians asking questions in order
to try and mitigate their own ignorance
in some way
i'm really fascinated by the fact that
you said you went into comedy because
you thought
that that is where people go to talk and
express themselves you know and
challenge the norm
because that is never ever how i've ever
perceived comedy
comedy is yeah gone well i was going to
say you're probably
a fair bit younger than me so you may
not have not not have been around
when people like big bill hicks and
george carlin
uh and other richard pryor these are all
probably before your time
and these were comedians who who they
were very funny
but the purpose of their shows was also
to make you think and to make you
question things
and if you if you get a chance to go
back and have a look at some of their
clips you'll see that these are people
who are really asking you to not buy
into the system
to go what is wrong with the picture you
know
whether it was and it was on all sorts
of issues it was whether
you know is the american dream really
that realistic george carlin has a great
bit about it
he has brilliant bits about the erosion
of language where he talks about how
certain words are being substituted now
and again i'm sure we'll talk about that
that is something that's happening in a
very big way at the moment
um you know where's bill hicks he talked
a lot about for example
why you know he talked a lot about drugs
he was a guy who took drugs
he smoked and he loved all of that and
he
talked about how it seems like all the
drugs that we're allowed to take
uh alcohol tobacco uh you know i'm
having a cup of tea right now all the
things that we're allowed to do
they are all things that allow you to
function
in the normal society and be a good
drone
right whereas the drugs that open your
mind the drugs that make you think
creatively the drugs that make you
question
should i be going to a nine-to-five job
should i be taking orders from some boss
i don't like should have
he was saying well maybe let's have a
think about why that's happening right
so he bill hicks was someone who was a
bit more conspiratorial in his thinking
uh but the point was that he was someone
who made you think and he made you
question things
um and he became quite iconic because he
died
very young uh and and so these were the
people that inspired me to go into
comedy whereas you and
it's this is the generational divide
you've probably grown up watching tv
loads of woke people running their their
crap down your throat on tv
because that's who that's comedy right
and that's and
you know i feel so bad for you and your
generation because
you've really missed out on the on what
i think were the golden
days of comedy and maybe i hope that
the pushback against this woke stuff
that you've been watching on tv and
people of your age have been
i hope the pushback against that
generates a new golden age of comedy
i've kind of been rather hopefully
predicting that that would happen
for some time it's not happening just
yet but it is
starting to happen people like ryan long
and others
doing comedy of of a different slan
i think it will potentially be something
in the future that i'm really
excited about yeah i should take back
that initial statement because actually
i'm a huge charlie chaplin fan
um i think his work is so beautiful it
really speaks to me
on like a humor level but also on a
spiritual level
um the music as well and yeah of course
charlie chaplin totally
um you know stuck it to the man stuck it
to the system and everything so no
you're totally right
um so when for you did you think that
shift really changed because
really if you know you go into comedy
and you think that this is all about um
questioning the establishment and then
suddenly it's actually not
and in my lifetime from what i've seen
comedy is just a bunch of woke people
other than michael mcintyre who's
excellent um you know
he stays away from that um you must have
really noticed a change in society at
what point was that
well i think as we were talking about
earlier it was it was probably around
brexit and the election of donald trump
that just seemed to explode people's
heads and i know i was someone like i
say it was
probably uh left leaning i was i don't
think i was ever woke but i was
certainly not
you know on the far right or on the
right or whatever this
all this nonsense is i was just someone
who i've always thought that the most
important thing in life is to make your
own mind up about things to look at the
evidence
to judge things as you see them to judge
people as you see them
and not to allow yourself to to get
embroiled in other people's
emotional incontinence about what's
happening right
and i think what we've seen over the
last five years is that
a lot of people they want to do that
they want
to see everything through the prism of
this is the worst thing that's ever
happened these people are evil
anyone who disagrees with me is the
worst possible person
i think social media obviously has a
huge part to play in this it's amplified
the divisions and it made them deeper
and more painful um so i think it was
around those two
triggers i think brexit and trump really
sent
a lot of people absolutely nuts and
seeing that troubles me because you know
growing up in the soviet union and
my most of my family were uh were in the
gulags in one shape or form or another
for the things that they said that they
were not supposed to say or for the
wrong opinions that they had or
for something they'd done to me seeing a
society
descend into unthinking
seeing a society descend into this herd
mentality where we're all like
sheep and we're all supposed to follow
some particular narrative
because cnn or the new york times or the
guardian of the bbc
uh are pumping this stuff out to me that
was very worrying and
it's the same thing now and again i'm
sure we'll talk about it when i see
the unthinking when it comes to
lockdowns and masks and whatever no look
the pandemic is real and
of course people have to take
precautions and all of that but
when the science says you know masks
don't seem to work
right and in fact one of the things i
noticed straight away when the mask
mandates came out was
i predicted that it would actually make
covert easier to spread because what
happens when put on people put on mask
is like when people put on bicycle
helmets
they become more confident and in in the
case of mass it means
they stop socially distancing and it's
the first thing that happened right
so you've got this situation where
people are making decisions based on
what that makes them feel good or makes
them feel virtuous
as opposed to what's actually real and
that's to me
is very worrying because i've seen
societies descend
and i've read about societies and my
family has lived in societies
that descended into this emotional thing
that becomes a snowball effect and
people aren't
that they're almost like their brain
isn't there anymore they're just part
of some kind of brain big brain
operation and they're all following in
one direction without thinking for
themselves
and that bothers me a lot there yeah
it's like yuri basmanov said there's
this like really famous
clip which i watch all the time um i'm
slightly obsessed with this topic um
but you know he sort of says you society
won't know what is coming
until you physically feel um you know
whether it's like the pain or you know
just not to quote exactly but until
you're like taken to the gas chambers
basically like you won't know what is
coming
until it is literally there so my
question to you is
why is that this clamp down on
you know freedom of speech dialogue
conversation
because i'll tell you this you and i
haven't said anything derogatory
yet we haven't said anything
controversial just yet
and i can tell you give me time give you
time i cannot i can tell you
for a matter of fact that my
monetization on youtube
just because of a few things we have
said will be limited i will then have to
actively
um request for it to be put back to
normal and it probably will because we
haven't said anything bad
but it you know it's just that like if
we were talking about feminism and we
were like you know
women are oppressed and you know we need
to help the women even help the jews as
well you know both jewish we can speak
openly
um you know then it probably wouldn't be
um limited
but why is it starting even with brexit
you know
back then it like for me i do think
brexit was a key turning point in the uk
when
those divisions really started because
obviously just for the people who aren't
british
mostly an american following the uk has
always been very calm
it's been very calm we never had huge
tensions um just another thing i'll say
before it is like i remember when i was
younger and i was maybe about
12 or 13. i i remember when
an election was going on and i thought
to myself god imagine living in the 60s
when like your vote really mattered
wouldn't it be really cool if your vote
matters wouldn't it be really cool to
like protest and fight for something
because now society is just boring years
later here we are so
this division you know not being allowed
to say things where did that come from
well there's a lot of different answers
to that question because there are many
it's a complicated subject there are
technological factors
uh there are there are social factors
there are historical factors so one of
the things i think
2016 was really about and donald trump
if you've got a mostly american audience
everything we say about brexit will
apply equally
uh to the election of donald trump uh i
think
uh 2016 represented uh working class
people
mostly working-class people being fed up
of being ruled by an elite that
increasingly didn't care about their
concerns
so as the jobs were being shipped off to
china and the united states
as in the uk people were coming in from
eastern europe and look i'm an immigrant
from eastern europe myself i've got
nothing against people coming to a
different country and trying to make a
better life for themselves but
when a large number of people come into
a country in a short period of time
it causes tension it causes downward
pressure on wages it causes people to
lose their jobs
it causes competition for housing in the
society which already has a problem with
with housing so this was happening
but the elites the people who were
making the political decisions
their experience of those processes was
completely different
their jobs weren't being shipped off
their jobs weren't being lost
their wages weren't falling they were
getting cheaper nannies coming even
coming in from eastern europe and
looking after their their privileged
kids
so so the people making the decisions
had lost touch
completely with the majority of society
with ordinary people and so to me
2016 was an outcry from those people who
were given for the first time in a long
time
an opportunity to say enough
listen to us as well and i think that is
what happened
in 2016 and of course the pampered elite
who've had
their hands on the tiller for all this
time didn't like that they didn't want
people to be able to say
what they're saying that's why they they
got all their trump cards out the racism
stuff the bigotry the xenophobia
all of that stuff became so big because
it was a tool that they used to try and
shut people up
so that's the political part of it the
technological part of it is
the truth is we have created these
platforms youtube twitter facebook etc
which
they are like the printing press on
steroids and
i'm sure you will be aware the printing
press when it was first
rolled out on the mass scale caused 200
200 years two centuries of religious
warfare
strife conflict and tolerance because
suddenly people were able to questions
than that question the narratives that
they were being fed
by their version of the mainstream media
at the time which was
the priests the aristocrats etc they
were being told one thing and suddenly
you could read the bible for yourself
right yeah and if you certainly could
find that there's nothing in the bible
about
you know bending the knee to to your
priest or whatever was the you know
whatever it was that those divides were
at the time so
um to me that the technological part of
it is also
a big part of it and look the technology
is so immensely powerful i don't think
any of us have really worked
out how it should be controlled or
regulated because
you know in the early days of the
internet it was a kind of wild wild west
and while i
enjoyed it and to me that was fun i also
think that the world we live in now
to just say there should be absolutely
no restrictions on anything
on the internet is a little bit naive
and impractical that's also not going to
happen right
the ability to disseminate information
that has very significant impact on the
real world
is so huge now that i think what we're
all struggling with is
how does that need to be controlled
without infringing on people's rights
but also with an understanding of the
tremendous power of these tools
there's so much to uncover and break
down and as
you talk i'm like writing like words and
things and there's something that you
spoke about
um you touched on the church right
so the church versus more information
which kind of took away their power um
something which
is really a really interesting
distinction which i've noticed between
the uk and the usa
is the usa has this patriotism for the
flag and freedom
and then so on that's kind of
self-explanatory in the uk we're not
really allowed to be patriotic
i don't know if you've noticed that as
an immigrant or whatever
but we're sort of not really allowed to
be patriotic here and the way in which
we show our patriotism is through our
social services our national health
service our nhs
and this is this is something which
spooked me so you can tell me how you
feel about it
so during like the key moment of the
lockdown last year
um every thursday night at 8 pm it was
became a ritual
everybody would go outside and clap for
the national health
service now i found it odd because it's
very like
number one what does that do doesn't
really do anything okay
it kind of creeped me out because they
can't hear you it doesn't do anything it
doesn't add any value to it
and it's like group thing it's like
doing something for no reason
doing something for the sake of doing
and then it's like you're bowing down to
a higher power higher power
which you're actually not allowed to
criticize
in the uk like if you criticize the nhs
that is akin to criticizing the church
back in the day
is there something going on there like
what is up with that
you know especially we can move on to
talking about the pandemic and
everything that's going on and lockdowns
and
vaccine passports because that obviously
is a huge topic right now but
we are literally not allowed to have
freedom of speech like we are literally
not allowed to say
hang on why were nhs health workers you
know dancing on tick tock if
you know whatever it is you're just not
allowed to say it i wonder if you have
any opinion on patriotism the nhs being
akin to the church
in today's world yeah there's a lot to
unpick there there's quite a bit i
disagree with you on actually
yeah but um so to me the clapping for
the nhs
i i think i might have clapped a few
times and probably not very much
but to me i don't have a problem in a
pandemic with people
giving nurses and doctors the feeling
that they're extra appreciated in a time
when there's an extra strain and an
extra risk to being a worker and nhs i
have many friends who are doctors and
nurses
uh i personally didn't see that as a
particularly nefarious thing
uh where i would definitely agree with
you and i'm writing my first book called
an immigrant's love letter to the west
uh it was initially titled an
immigrant's love letter to britain and
it's really all about
this thing that you're raising which is
the inability to to be patriotic
george orwell wrote about this way back
when he said you know there's a certain
thing in britain that uh among
intellectuals among the british
intelligentsia that they would rather be
seen
stealing from the poor box than standing
to attention during the national anthem
right there's this self-loathing that's
always been very popular in britain
which i don't understand
i'm not you know i'm probably more
patriotic about britain than most
british people
yeah because i just i think it's a great
country and i think uh it's to be
respected but look
there's a lot there's a lot going on
underneath the surface of that and i
think
one part of that is there's a certain
discomfort
with the idea of patriotism because
people have somehow tied into
tied it into like hardcore nationalism
and people think that if you
love your country that means you hate
everybody else and you are
against other people and particularly in
a multi-ethnic society as britain
is there is the sort of feeling that
somehow being patriotic about britain
is tied into being pro-white or somehow
excluding of other minorities
so that's why people then seek these
things like the nhs
because that's not something you can
accuse of being like
nationalistic in that way right
and and there's this deep it's amazing
how for
a society is probably the least racist
society in the world
there's this deep discomfort with any
sort of
pride or patriotism about your country
whereas to me the history of britain is
overcoming
the those boundaries and those terrible
things that happened in the past whether
that's
the atrocities committed by the british
empire or slavery
or how generations of migrants were
treated when they came in the 50s and
60s
and look at look at us now look how much
better society is right
to me that's a story to be proud of and
to me the british identity
like the american identity the american
identity even more so
is brilliant in this way because the
moment you set foot in america
and you say i buy into the valleys of
your country
i want to pursue my dreams i want the
freedom
and the risk that comes with freedom to
do what i want to do for the betterment
of me
and my family i want to contribute to
the society i want to build things i
want to
learn things i i want to create things
and i am now an american
and it doesn't matter if you're brown
black green yellow white whatever it
doesn't matter
the moment you buy into the idea you
become
american and to me that is what the
british culture should be as well
yeah you don't have you don't have to be
a particular color or gender or whatever
to be british
the british identity should be these are
the things that we believe
but dare ask claire dare ask a normal
standard british person
what are british values they will run
away from you
like you've just asked them to join the
bnp because that is the attitude that
people in this country have to
patriotism to them
any idea of being you know being proud
of your country or thinking that it's
actually quite a good country that it
has values that are important
to them that is scary that is absolutely
scary and that's something i would love
to change i would love to make it okay
for people to have a healthy love for
their country in this country which
frankly is quite merited if you compare
this country to many others around the
world
oh yeah this country you know look the
west is
great well was great i don't know where
we're going we'll talk about it
in a minute but absolutely and i i think
you know so many people
especially from you know eastern europe
run to the uk
given all the atrocities that we've seen
throughout the 20th century and how that
is you know that is still
it's still sort of existing today the um
the the after effects of it and so on
but yeah you make a really good point
and the point actually is
the difference between multi-culturalism
and multi-ethnicity and things like that
because culturalism is a disaster
multiple exactly
completely different yeah exactly and
you can't have these conversations
and you may like i think what you said
is entirely spot on you know like
come to a country add value build if you
want to make a better life for yourself
please make a better life yourself use
use the country soak up everything you
could possibly can but don't come to a
country
and try and impose everything that
you're running away from
and if you do it you know if it's
to be honest it's kind of like we're
getting to a point even even you know
forget immigration but like just within
a society where nobody is able to
um just accept each other for what they
are everything has to be imposed now you
know and
i feel even our language is changing our
language is having to be shifted and
imposed no it's
it's she her it's they them you know
it's not just like
him her done you know everything is
gone the thing with the thing with
language is i've written some
articles about this and again this will
be something i i talk about in my book
it's do you know where the term
political correctness comes from
no i actually don't tell me the term
political correctness it never had
anything to do with
snowflakes and all this other stuff that
people like to say the term political
correctness comes from the soviet union
and it was also being used
in maoist china and the point of the
term politically correct
is to shut someone up if someone says a
blatant truth
you could say well comrade this is
factually correct
but it is politically incorrect which
means it is inconvenient to the party
for you to be saying this thing that is
true right
so political correctness comes the point
of political correctness is to prevent
ideas which are factually accurate from
being expressed
to prevent offending or upsetting or
challenging the mainstream narrative of
the dogma of that society in the present
time
and look at the language i mean you talk
about she her and that's that's a bit of
a niche issue but look at other things
so think about things like tolerance
right the most
the people who are the most
quote-unquote tolerant right
tolerate no opposition to their views
right
the people who bang on endlessly about
diversity
don't want anyone with a difference of
opinion in their space
the people who want a safe space what
does a safe space looks like
look like it's a space in which people
like me and you would be unsafe
right it's a place where people like me
and you would not be welcome when people
talk about welcoming
a welcoming space or being welcoming
what they really mean is
this is a place where people who think
like us come together
to have our conversation and we don't
engage in robust debate we don't engage
in discussion
so what has happened in the last 20 30
years is
all of these words have had their
meanings entirely substituted
tolerance now means intolerance
diversity now means people with
different skin colors who all think the
same thing
right welcoming now means excluding
people and
inclusion means excluding people who
don't agree with you
so what has happened linguistically over
the last 15 20 years
is a complete substitution of meaning on
a grand
level and this is one of the things that
george carlin who we mentioned earlier
the comedian
he talked about this a lot he talked
about how politicians and political
activists and actors
use language to misrepresent the meaning
of what's happening
and to conceal the truth to conceal the
truth
even the multiculturalism of
multi-ethnic that's why this distinction
is so important
a multi-ethnic society is a society in
which people from different races
come together and live peacefully
together under one
culture they're all british they're all
american
they're all russian they're all this
they're all that right
a multicultural society what that really
means is it's not a society
it's a it's disparate groups of people
who coexist in the same geographical
space
but don't actually have an overarching
identity that they can bind themselves
into
and that is a recipe for disaster and
that is a recipe
frankly for conflict because if you
allow people to live in the same space
but remain tribally different that will
inevitably pit them against each other
and that's what we've seen
in recent times particularly every time
anything happens
in in israel and in gaza suddenly you
see
that jews are now being attacked in a
way that they've never been and look i'm
not someone who bangs on about my
jewishness at all
it's not that important to me i'm not
religious i just noticed that as a very
easy example to observe
about what happens when you tribalize
people and you allow everybody to
to live in in a society that's really
that they're not really a part of
that they're not integrating into in
many like it was shock to me
when i went into my local surgery gp
surgery in london
and they gave me a leaflet in 25
different languages
and i was like wait i thought we lived
in britain
right i thought we're we're all here to
be
british now of course you know i'll
bring my russian
cynical our background into it and
someone else will bring their food and
someone else will bring this and that
and whatever
uh and that's great but we're all here
to learn the language we're all here to
buy into the values we're all here
to to buy into a certain mindset uh
you know and we have the freedom within
that to be different of course we do but
yeah but
we're all buying into a certain set of
things and the moment you don't do that
i think that's a recipe for very
dangerous things to happen
i think your perspective is fascinating
because you are an immigrant that is why
it's so fascinating
you're like don't accommodate for me
don't change your language for me i will
be
i'm happy to accept your values that is
why my family left i'm really fascinated
i think you're yeah you know when it
comes to like
issues on feminism for example i feel
like because i'm a woman i'm allowed to
talk about it you know if you're black
you're allowed to talk about racism
you're an immigrant you're literally
allowed to say why do you have all these
languages this is britain
find that fascinating um i have a
question for you something which i
didn't think i would ask you but i'll
ask you anyway
um so you spoke about obviously you
spoke about being jewish
um it's really interesting um my
audience i don't even know if they know
or not but i am jewish and i don't
really talk about it much
um mainly because i hate identity
politics
so much hate it with every bone in my
body i think it's an
absolute scam of which i was recently
scammed by but we can
talk about that at another time oh yeah
um
but okay you talk about safe spaces now
when we talk about minorities
jewish people don't fall into that which
is fascinating to me so
you know jewish people don't fall into
um
the you know either you're the woman
black asian
gay lgbt we really don't fall into that
like left-wing
protected bubble at all
why is that not that i want to i could
not care less please
no one misunderstand me i do not care
i'm happy just to like
deal with myself and look after myself
but why don't we why aren't we allowed
in that like protected bubble
well if you think historically about
this issue
what is the most oppressed group in the
history of humanity
i don't know i don't like to answer that
question i i mean i probably know the
answer but i won't answer it you can
answer it
well i'm only asking this because i
think it's
it highlights the ridiculousness of
of the conversation around the issue of
oppression right
i would be saying this very same thing
if i weren't jewish i just think jews
are a very good example of this
conversation so
jews have been persecuted for what two
millennia
uh including 70 years ago
an attempt to eradicate all of them from
the planet earth and
succeeding largely in taking out about
40 i think it was of the total jewish
population of the world
in the space of six years right so to me
that that i mean that
of all the claims to oppression i would
say that's pretty high up there and by
the way
while the nazis were exterminating jews
in
germany and in eastern europe uh it's
not like in the soviet union where i
come from jews were loved and
revered and whatever the the slogan in
russia was
kill the jews save russia right so this
is a minority that has been
attacked beaten murdered persecuted
for millennia now jews as you rightly
say don't seem to qualify for that
persecution status
and i i don't want it i don't that's
what i'm saying neither do i i
don't want this crap and i don't see the
world through being jewish it's not
actually
that relevant to me i just it's
interesting to me that that
this same thing will is already
happening with asian americans in
particular
uh the korean the chinese uh and
and the reason of course is the jews
despite being the most oppressed
minority in history
uh just like the asian americans who
japanese americans were interred
in america during world war ii they were
literally put in camps
right and still they're literally one of
the most high earning demographics in
america
why is that because of their culture
because of their practices because
they they value education they
prioritize success
uh you know all the tropes about jewish
mothers and fathers and
you know what what a good jewish girl
and good jewish boy looks like
that's culture and that culture teaches
you that it's important to get a good
education it's important to work hard
it's important to be successful
it's important to to make money all of
these things
drive a group of people forward and
allow them to thrive
despite the fact that they face genuine
obstacles
in their advancement right uh so the the
problem
that the jews and asian americans and
others increasingly face
is that if you're successful you don't
fit
the identity politics ideology because
identity politics ideology
is based on victimhood and it's based on
failure
right if you're not doing well you are
therefore
uh oppressed and if you're doing well
well you can't be oppressed right
even if you are even if you are if
literally half of your people have just
been killed well you're still doing
well because you make a lot of money and
whatever i think that's it just doesn't
fit the stupid narrow-minded ideology
and so
that's why they have to cast out asian
americans they discriminate them against
uh against asian americans in education
in the united states
you literally have to have a higher
score on your test to go to harvard if
you're
asian-american than you do if you're
white or if you're black or if you're
latino
so there's active discrimination going
on because it doesn't fit into the
little identity politics heads that
your your oppression and your success
levels aren't necessarily connected
because
the main point of of i think this
conversation should be layers
if you work hard and if you do certain
things
and if you study and you get a good
education you can be successful
even if you are genuinely disadvantaged
and instead of telling people that
instead of telling people
you can make it you can be successful
just follow these steps
instead they need people to be quote
unquote oppressed
they need people to struggle because
then they from their
elite perch can look down upon those
people and say
i am speaking on your behalf in my 300th
pound
thousand pound a year diversity job at
the bbc
i am looking after you poor oppressed
person
as i sip my shabbly in a trendy london
bar
right that is what it's about it's it's
a scam like you say
it's it's an industry diversity
inclusion
all of this stuff it's an industry for
elite people mostly elite white people
to advance their own career you put that
so wonderfully
um that was absolutely brilliant i
totally agree with you
it literally is if you tell somebody
from day one that you are oppressed
you are screwed i saw this video of um
mila kunis and ashton kutcher i don't
know if you know the video
i'm talking about but for those who
don't know the video it was terrible
terrible this is what happened they've
got two kids i've got a girl and a boy
and they said that they said to their
son
that they will always take their
daughter to bed first and read her a
bedtime story
because outside of their little house
girls don't get to go first you so
basically are saying to
their daughter you are going to be
oppressed when you grow up in society
therefore
we are going to level the playing field
and let you go to bed first you get the
kiss good night first
i mean that is so detrimental it is so
unbelievable
i have two brothers and one of my
brothers
literally like if i say i can't do
something he will scream at me like i'm
in trouble if i say i can't do something
um you know if i say yeah but it's
easier for you because you're a man i am
in trouble if i do that
and that mentality that alternative kind
of brainwashing
and indoctrination of you can do
anything regardless of what you look
like or your gender or anything
has helped me do what i do nothing
nothing can stop me now because no you
know i don't if
you know if somebody laughs at me for
being female or whatever it is
nothing bothers me now because i know
that i can do that i can do whatever i
want to do because i've been told that i
can
literally indoctrinating somebody with
the mindset that you're going to fail in
society is going to hate you and destroy
you
destroys you and that keeps people
hooked
yeah yeah yeah and anyone who does that
to
children uh that to me is child abuse
anyone who indoctrinates children with
the ideology of failure
is abusing that child and is damaging
them
for life and is having a huge impact on
their life chances as well because
so much of life not everything in life
you know bad things happen to good
people and all of that but
so much of life is about resilience it's
about
the willingness to keep going and i
learned that the hard way you know like
i said when i was sleeping on the street
and all of these
my life was very very difficult but it
never occurred to me that you wouldn't
i wouldn't be able to turn around even
in that moment when
when i felt so down i just knew that you
know
that's not my destiny my destiny is to
make make a success of my life
and if something isn't happening there's
i'm not saying it's all down to me
but there is something i can do
differently to improve that situation
and if you're not teaching your children
that
i think you're not setting them up for
the best opportunity in life so
it's good for you to have a brother with
some toxic masculinity i suppose
oh yeah he's full of toxic masculinity
we support toxic masculinity in our
family
no absolutely i you know i really i
really appreciate what you said i think
that is
that's what it comes down to um you know
meritocracy pulling yourself up nobody's
coming to save you
um but let's move on to talk about
today's world because
we have seen what is going on to me is
is really concerning
um i don't mean to be doom and gloom and
i really don't want to be and i you know
i do hope that
things can turn around and i genuinely
think that things will turn around
eventually
but we have seen lockdowns these
vaccine passports are going to be
mandatory and it's odd because you can't
have a conversation about this and
for me it's just so obvious why a
vaccine passport is not a good thing
you know what about body autonomy what
about what the left said when it comes
to abortion the left told me
that as a woman i have a right to choose
right i
my body my choice that's what the left
told me but now the left is telling me
that it's not my body my choice so
what is your take what is going on you
know is there a light at the end of this
authoritarian tunnel well see i wish
that you were right when you say it's
the left that won this
yeah you're right i'm sorry it's not
just the left it's actually
quite a lot of people on the right as
well uh it's
uh what we've seen and i know you want
this to be a positive conversation
and i am someone who is naturally
naturally extremely optimistic about
things
okay like we've just talked about i
believe that anything can be overcome i
don't agree with you the vaccine
passports are going to be mandatory
we're going to fight and i think we're
going to win that fight i think they are
they are claiming that they're going to
introduce them
in order to scare young people into
getting the vaccine which by the way
my position on the vaccine is like this
if you're elderly or if you're
vulnerable for clinical reasons if i
were in your position
i would definitely take the vaccine
right if you want to take the vaccine
great good for you if you are young and
healthy and not
at risk i think you should assess the
risks and rewards of taking the vaccine
on its own merits
i think the only possible reason to take
the vaccine
is your own medical needs right
your own medical needs to protect you
that is why you would take the vaccine
or not take the vaccine so for an
elderly person or a clinically
vulnerable person
taking a vaccine makes sense to me on a
reward
and risk ratio basis right for a younger
person i think the choice is more
difficult and people should make their
own decision on that
but the vaccine passports and dominic
crabb our foreign secretary said this
explicitly yesterday
are designed to coerce young people into
taking the vaccine
now this is deeply unethical because
what this does is it changes the
relationship between
the state and the citizen and the way it
does that is what they're really saying
is
we're going to take away your natural
rights your right to go to a
club or to a pub or to associate with
others or to see a play or to see a
comedy show
or to be out in public or to go to a
supermarket or to go to a concert
these are your natural rights lair
that's that's not something boris
johnson invented and
assigned to me and you to be able to do
those are
god-given rights if you believe in god
or natural rights if you don't those are
things
that all human beings have by virtue of
being human
and what they're saying is we're going
to take that away from you not because
we need to
not because it's for safety not because
we need to protect you other people
around you
we're going to take those rights away
from you because it's going to force you
to do something else that we want and
this is completely immoral
it's deeply unethical and it opens a
pandora's box of gigantic proportions
what about overweight people if this is
about protecting the healthcare system
overweight people put a tremendous
amount of strain and i am so i say this
is someone who used to be overweight
a tremendous amount of strain on the
national health service right
so do we take their driving licenses
away so they have to walk everywhere to
lose weight
is that the next step because it's the
same principle
right it's exactly the principle so it's
deeply unethical
now add to that the fact that numerous
government government ministers
said repeatedly that this wouldn't
happen the vaccines minister
in britain nadeem zahawi said the
vaccine passports are discriminatory
and that they're not going to introduce
them and he gave
my friend dan wooden a guarantee on his
show that they wouldn't happen
this is what he said and two months
later they're now trying to sell us on
this
it's completely unacceptable it's
outrageous
but the problem is and this is where i
say even though i'm optimistic about
things personally and i i cultivate i
think a personal resilience that i think
is essential that we've talked about
the thing that i do find very depressing
is not the government the government are
always going to in the crisis
they're always going to clamp down
they're always trying to take more power
for themselves they will always do this
the thing that bothers me is the public
what we've seen in the last
year and a half is that something we've
always known
is the truth right about half the public
uh i don't want to use unkind words but
it's
it's hard to avoid they will panic in
the situation of crisis
they will be scared and when they're
scared they will throw any principles
they have out of the window
and they will demand that things happen
to protect
them and it does not matter what the
principles at stakes are
at stake high does not matter what the
cost is it does not matter what the harm
is to other people
they will demand that people are forced
to do things they don't want to do it
put things in their body that they don't
want to put in there
etc because it makes them feel safer
right and that to me is the tragic side
of this we that we've seen
is half the public are absolutely on
board we've seen polls in this country
that show
20 of the public when surveyed
are in favor of 10 p.m curfews
even if there is no virus why
why why because in the situation of
panic people will quite happily
take your rights away if they think that
that makes them a little bit safer
i don't go out after 10 pm so no one
else should be
i don't go to nightclubs 30 say they
they would happily close clubs
forever absent a virus layer no virus
they still want clubs to close 30 of the
british public
in polls say that right so what we've
seen
is the the public in a moment of crisis
in a moment of fear
they reveal their inner authoritarianism
these are the same people who were
burning witches
blaming the jews for the plague
these are the same people who were
saluting hitler and i'm not saying
they're nazis at all
what i'm saying is these people are
conformist and in a moment of
fear and panic they will go with
whatever they're being given
you're absolutely spot on i mean the
thing which
concerns me about europe um is that we
don't have the same kind of
rights entrenched often as america so
often i talk about america as this free
country and i know america as well is
very much at the heart of
this huge change and division that we're
seeing in society
but america still has their first and
second amendment america still has a
large population
that are going to say no to this
we don't have that kind of mentality
entrenched here and europe very much
is controlled by its past and its
authoritarian past i know it's not all
of europe
but it you know it has those um i was
trying to look for the word earlier it's
about like there's like room
like side effects like breadcrumbs from
the past you know
and that's what concerns me about the uk
and i wonder if you
sort of feel that america's rights are
more entrenched given they have that
first second amendment you know you come
in you come to texas and you try and
tell them to inject themselves with a
foreign substance no they'll show you
their guns and they'll tell you to leave
you know it it just has more like i
always say
i always say this doesn't need to get
into a gun debate at all i don't really
need to get into that but i always say
if jewish people had guns
not just jewish people if everybody if
germans had guns
back in the 40s i just don't think the
holocaust would have happened
because you even had germans who wanted
to protect jewish people but obviously
couldn't because they didn't have the
means to do that
um so i wonder whether you think you
know their rights are more entrenched
just because they have those bill of
rights i do i
i i do need to pick you up on the
holocaust go on because it's important
and this isn't i i
my position on guns is that if i i
personally
don't think that guns in the society
make it
better for individuals living in normal
times right i don't
okay if i lived in america though i
would definitely own a gun
if you live in a society where guns are
allowed i'm happening
yeah it's different you couldn't
implement guns in the uk at all
it's different totally i'm with you no
i'm with you on that but but
historically
america is what america is and you're
never going to get rid of the second
amendment you just have to accept that
and live with that and that
and in that society i would train to use
firearms i would be responsible with it
but i would definitely have firearms
right
uh but on the holocaust point just very
quickly it's a little bit simplistic
that argument
because uh because the the
what happens in societies that have that
sort of authoritarianism totalitarianism
they don't suddenly declare you know
what now we're killing the jews
right or now we're taking people off to
the gulags and this is what alexander
solzhenitsyn wrote about
he said that if we'd resisted if we'd
resisted
and if every time the kgb came in uh to
take someone away
we all ambushed them in the bottom of
our building with
axes and guns and frying pans and
whatever
they would never been able to do that
the problem is is getting p enough
people
to rise up against something like that
all at once when they don't feel
personally challenged
right and so that's really the issue
because look look look at the thing with
vaccine particles look how many people
now are saying
uh what what's your problem look just
take the vaccine
just take the vaccine just take the
vaccine part what's your problem with it
so even now let's say that everybody had
guns uh you still wouldn't really be
able to do it because
the majority of the public would be on
the side of the tyrannical government if
the government became tyrannical
so it's a bit more complicated than that
i i i see the argument there's some
merits to her
but i do think it's a little bit more
complex than that but
coming back to america i love america
precisely for this very reason that
it's a country that is not entrenched in
a particular
way of thinking they still are trying to
work out
what is the best way to run a society
and they're not prepared
to just throw their freedoms in the bin
because they're a society born of
revolution
born of the fight for freedom and so i
think that is something i really
admire about our americans and and in
the in in western europe
we don't have that at all in france
they're rolling out these vaccine
passports in italy they're having
punch-ups in parliament about it
in greece people are on the streets uh
but the governments uh
feel very comfortable i think and part
of the reason no doubt
is that the people who are out in the
streets protesting aren't able to cause
anarchy on the mass scale and no one
wants any loss of life
at all but i think the government would
be a lot more cautious if they were a
little bit more afraid of their people
and i
i don't have a problem with that that's
kind of what i'm getting i feel
you know potentially just going back to
that holocaust example
if people were armed i don't know
whether the situation would have
escalated or been able to
escalate um you know i know that what
happened was very unprecedented and now
we can look back at history and we can
take what we learn and we can say
that reminds me of that that kind of
rhetoric reminds me of that you know
passports mandates i know i know but see
in nazi germany for example the way you
would have done it is very simple you
would have said
well you know the jews are a little bit
suspect so uh
they can't own uh rifles uh
and then the jews are actually a little
bit more suspect they can't own
handguns and then before you know it the
jews don't have any guns anyway with the
majority of the public
going along with it right because the
majority of the public won't make a
stand on principle they will only make a
stand on what's convenient for them
and i know this is very kind of black
pill from from me in terms of
the way i'm communicating it i'm just
saying i i prefer to face the reality
than to have a an overly optimistic view
of things even though naturally i'm very
optimistic i just think
you have to stare at the truth in the
face and the truth is
the people who will give you
authoritarianism are not corrupt evil
politicians
it's the half the population who will go
along with them
they're the ones that are making it
happen and as long as they're not on
your
side even if you have an ar-15 you're
not really going to be able to do very
much about it
yeah you see that it's that point isn't
it because i saw a really funny video of
boris johnson the other day
i don't know if you saw the video but
for those watching there was a video of
the prime minister of
the united kingdom struggling to open an
umbrella it was hilarious
it popped open it flipped it was so
funny and then you look at this guy and
you're like oh my god you're the person
responsible for
all this authoritarianism that we've
seen and so two things makes me wonder
like number one is that actually coming
from you
you seem like an all-right bloke you
know like i think we could have a great
time like you know just going for a
for a chat and a drink whatever like you
know you seem great
is it coming from him is it coming from
the people allowing it to happen
is it coming from the eu i do know that
you know this is one of the reasons why
people did vote to leave the eu because
of their authoritarian tendencies which
we're clearly seeing with the vaccine
passports rolling out across europe you
know
where do you think these overall
this authoritarianism is sort of coming
from well
okay consider this think about the
british cabinet i know for your american
viewers this may be a
bit of a niche niche thing to get into
but
uh if you go down the list of the people
who are in cabinet people like
rishi sunak the the the chancellor the
finance minister in other countries
uh sajid javid nadim zahawi
these are all multi multi multi
millionaires
who are nonetheless in government right
they're taking a crappy salary they have
the the the the official government
salary is almost
no money to them at all right they're
taking a tremendous amount of hatred and
flag from the public they're constantly
in the gaze of the media it has a hugely
detrimental effect on their personal
lives on their marriages on their kids
on the whole thing so why are they doing
this why why do all these people want to
be
in the governing party now the the the
sort of
uh the sort of positive vision is well
they want to make a difference they want
to contribute to society
yeah well maybe but you know especially
with men
men crave power you know these people
are there because they want power they
want to be able
to shape the future of the world and
that's at the heart of
most human beings right but these people
who who who already have millions of
pounds they're not going into it to
profit financially from some dodgy deal
they're going into it because it's a
status competition
for power right so the fact that boris
johnson looks and behaves like a buffoon
doesn't mean
that he is a buffoon he's someone who
wanted to be king of the world when he
was five
this is a quote direct quote these
people
are obsessed with power and they want it
and when they get the opportunity like
the last 18 months
to exercise more of it to tell more
people what to do
to take more freedoms away in the name
of safety and as they see the public
cravenly acquiescing to that
they want more and they can do it and
that's why they're there they're there
for the power
they're there for the power and now
they've got it of course they're having
a good time
and boris johnson looking like an idiot
is no he's a that's an act
boris johnson is a very driven power
hungry man
just like the rest of them yeah it's
very interesting i mean i i didn't
really
take that approach but i guess you're
right because to be honest like i would
love to
make a better world but i don't really
it's not really in me like i don't
really have
the drive to want to be a politician
for me i just want to make a better life
for myself and my family
so you're right like you can want to
make it make the world a better place
but with that has to come
the drive to wanting to be king of the
world
um as well like if you think about this
if you were starting from scratch
now completely from scratch and you
wanted to make the world a better
place would you go into politics
no because i feel like with politics
it's a never-ending cycle and even if
you do make it better
it will just be undone once you're gone
right but but the thing is you're also
very constrained if you wanted to make
the world a better place
you'd invent something that stops
plastic building up in the in the in the
ocean
right or you you'd help orphans in
africa or you'd build the church or
you'd build a school or you'd do
something practical right
and these people are millionaires who
could do all of that but they go into
politics right
why is that and the reason is they want
the power that it comes with
and so to me the fact that they are now
exercising this
this arbitrary power that they've given
themselves there's no surprise of why
to me i'm surprised that people are
surprised
you know just because we're coming up
towards the end i will just bring this
up now because i obviously
i i really enjoyed the conversation and
i think everything that you've said i i
really really agree you also speak
really eloquently which is really really
important when you're talking about
these kind of issues
we need people that can put it forward
in a very fair and clear manner
it's really important um but this is
actually you know you talk about what
would you do if you wanted to change the
world this is
a huge reason as to why i'm hugely
involved in cryptocurrency mainly
bitcoin and why
literally that's now the foundation of
my life and my
my career and my let's say humanitarian
work
because i do regard it as that it's so
wonderful to
have something which literally allows
you to opt out
something which governments can't
control like they can't control your
money
the eu want to make cryptocurrency um
they want to ban anonymous
cryptocurrency transactions so
i don't obviously i don't know how much
you know about cryptocurrency but
ultimately they are technology at the
top remember
yes i know you lost your bitcoin you
lost your bitcoin
you sold your bitcoin sorry i didn't
lose it i got it you sold it for it
no okay yeah which would be now around
like 60 grand but anyway
40 grand but anyway another time um but
for me having cryptocurrency is is such
a lifesaver it
it really brings me so much peace during
a time like this
um so before we went live i was telling
you i was going i was having a bit of a
rant and my rant was about
central bank digital currencies because
they are coming and essentially
they will be an extension of the current
monetary system
but they will take away any extra
privacy or anonymity that we had left
and it's just another way for
governments to just basically screw you
over and
that is why i find so much peace in
cryptocurrency
in bitcoin um and for me like that is
where the love comes from a lot of
people are like i'm in it for the tech
and i'm like now i'm in it for the
politics i'm in it for the freedom in it
for the revolution
um would you ever like consider
going more down that route in any manner
well it's one of the things that we
think about quite carefully at
trigonometry because
while we are not people who put out
content that's
you know likely to get banned or likely
to get taken down from youtube i mean we
do have controversial conversations
sometimes but i think we stayed fairly
within the the sort of overton window uh
we're pushing the boundaries of it every
now and again but i i think we we have a
responsible
approach to what we do uh but but but
the reality is
that we don't know what the truth what
the what the situation will be we've
seen people banned from
various platforms in the past past and
and obviously
the the the the bigger you get
the more uncancelable you become right
like
the point i started was if if anybody
said anything bad about me in a
newspaper
that would have had a detrimental impact
on my comedy career right
now i don't depend on anything like that
the only thing
i depend on is the existence of youtube
to do our show
and ways to convert that
into cash that i can spend now if the
government at some point decide to start
shutting down bank accounts of people
who've got the wrong opinions
you can totally see how an alternative
way of paying for things and receiving
money from our supporters
and whatever would work so i i can
totally see
it's just not something that i know
enough about but
as someone who's who understands the
context of everything else it it makes
perfect sense that you'd want to have
a way a medium of exchange that isn't
controlled by government
uh the only thing that i would say on
that front and again this may be the
black pill element of my thinking is
nothing you nothing that allows people
to keep
money out of the hands of government
will ever remain
unregulated for very long they will find
a way
so on that note and i totally understand
where you're coming from but this is why
bitcoin is so beautiful and i i really
use the word beautiful i know i sound
crazy but
i've written a book on this and it's
coming out really soon i'm so excited
you just look forward to reading it
thank you so much likewise i think the
name of
your upcoming book sounds absolutely
brilliant um that is such a smart a love
letter from an immigrant i think you
said it was it's
really really smart um but essentially
you just
can't ban a decentralized network that
is the beauty
and the genius of it like china for
example tried to ban it they shut down
um mining in many different provinces
of course it had had an effect on the
price but the price still remained above
its all-time high of twenty thousand
dollars back in 2017
um and now miners are literally just
moving
they're just relocating plugging in a
different place and we're starting to
see
the technology sort of kick back up
again like the hash rate difficulty
adjustment things like that we're
starting to see that come back
and the price is starting to recover and
that is what's so beautiful about it and
i think as well like
you know with politics on a grand scale
states governments provinces
organizations companies will have to
pick a side as we move forward and i
think we're seeing that anyway like not
the entire world has gone into lockdown
some places you know are totally open
and totally free
so i do think that some states
organizations nightclubs when it comes
to vaccine passports
will pick aside and so that is where the
miners bitcoin miners to help secure
the network we'll move to should
governments really try
um i think that i think it's it's it's
honestly amazing and it really gives me
hope um so yeah if you ever want to talk
more about it just let me know but um
but i just want to say thank you so much
um honestly it's been such a good
conversation
where can people find out more about you
and also what are you up to
in the next few months well i'm at
constantin kitchen on
on twitter and other social media the
show that i do with my co-host francis
is trigonometry as in trigger like a gun
trigger
uh we put out interviews with absolutely
fascinating people
everybody from your jordan petersons to
completely unknown people who have an
interesting
uh story and we also do
uh four raw shows a week where it's just
me and him two comedians
uh very politically and correctly joking
about the things that are going on
uh and being problematic in all sorts of
different ways uh
so yeah that i do that i'm on gb news
once a week on thursdays as well you can
there's plenty of me if you look and my
book is called an immigrant
love letter to the west and it's coming
out next year i am so excited to read
that honestly
constantine i want to thank you so much
it's been such a pleasure
um guys please follow um constantine he
always is offering incredible insight
and um i saw that you're on gb news that
is super cool gb news for those that
don't know is this new
new uk kind of alternative ish
media it's a bit more refreshing than
the usual news thanks for having me
absolute pleasure guys thanks for tuning
in and i will see you all next week bye
[Music]
[Applause]
bye